initial unemployment claims have seen  really little change while  pua initial claims are showing a  significant spike  dieter reporting more than 57 thousand  pua claims filed last week  that is an increase of about 45 thousand  just from the week before  when the total was just around twelve  thousand five hundred regular initial  claims total just over nine  thousand and that is up three hundred  and two claims or roughly three point  five percent  from the week before and if you are out  there looking for a job there are  several companies hiring right now we  have put together a list along with  links to  apply it's all right there on our  website at 8newsnow.com  and all you have to do is click on the  job board tab